pour un rappel au règlement
merci madame la Présidente sur la base
de l'article 153 sur les accès bill se
plaignait pas entendre le groupe
rassemblement national il va être servi
il reste
13800 heures
amendement pardon à débattre 13800
amendements à débattre au rythme actuel
nous débattons de 12 amendements à
l'heure c'est-à-dire qu'on a besoin de
1150 heures de débat c'est le choix du
gouvernement il reste quelques jours de
débat il reste deux jours ici à
l'Assemblée nationale et même si tous
les opposants retirent leurs amendements
il en restera 300 9 de la majorité il
est donc impossible de débattre de la
réforme des retraites dans ces
conditions aussi à l'initiative de
Marine Le Pen du groupe rassemblement
national nous avons déposé une motion de
censure spontanée comme l'article 49-2
de la Constitution nous le permet ainsi
et pour l'ensemble de des députés le
seul moyen de s'opposer à cette réforme
des retraites sera de voter cette motion
de censure
et je demande 5 minutes de suspension de
séance
elle est de droite la séance est
suspendue pour cinq minutes
[Applaudissements]